welcome back to dc thursday everyone
we are
here again with another episode to guide
you through the rapidly expanding and
fascinating
modern data ecosystem
i'm pete soderling i'm the founder of
data council and the data community fund
and today i'm here with sumadev mitra
from rudder stack and we're going to
discuss the marketing automation world
and how accurate customer data requires
specific infrastructure
we'll hear about suny dev's thoughts on
critical cdp design decisions
and learn about some of the important
architectural choices that they made at
rudderstack while building and bringing
the rudder stack open source product to
market
so sumidab is the co-founder and ceo of
rudderstack
he was previously the co-founder
of mariana iq which exited eight by
eight
prior to that he was the chief architect
at data domain which was acquired by emc
and before that he has a degree in a
degree in computer science from iit
delhi
and a phd in cs from the university of
illinois illinois at urbana-champaign
so sumitab i want to welcome you to dc
thursday
thanks pete i'm really humbled to be
here and i'm excited to be talking to
you today
yeah it's great to have you rudder stack
has been such an interesting company to
follow over the years and so i'm excited
to hear about the origin story and
your perspectives on the business and
and how you ended up bringing this
particular product to market
great yeah i mean i love talking about
respect so yeah thanks thanks again for
having me
so um before we get into the the rudder
stack parts of the story tell us a
little bit about your background
and how did you end up
um getting into data
yeah i mean
data was an interesting
part right i mean i right after my
undergrad i started a company with a
couple of my classmates
and
at that point we are kind of building
the next generation like palm pilots and
this was based out of india so there was
no like iphone and so on so like
so it really didn't start
my career in india it was more about
embedded systems and design and all that
stuff right but that company didn't do
so well and then i came for my phd
at urbana-champaign
and like when you go for grad school
like you kind of like pick an advisor
you like and like a topic you like and
so i ended up in this group
called uh like csci right so basically
the team
did a lot of high performance computing
and
and like simulations and rocket
simulations and so on so like that felt
cool i mean like
i got i had access to the the top i
think it was the third fastest computer
in the world and the fifth fastest like
there was a big center so and what my
group specifically did was
like a lot of data handling for these
simulations right so they're like
enormous amount of data was generated at
every stage of these rocket simulations
like yeah that's where my research group
like did a lot of work and that was
pretty much my introduction to data and
like yeah i mean uh
this was big data before big data was
cool in any sense i learned a lot and
and so on so that
stayed in this space forever
and so then what did you do after your
phd
yeah so after my phd
like uh i i i went to this company
called data domain so data domain
most of you have not heard about the the
company itself like the company did very
well but i think that the ceo is
probably more famous now frank
so he he is now a big shot he's a
ceo of snowflake he wrote a book today
and so on but like data domain was his
first company as a as as a ceo and in
fact like he
convinced me to join data domain over
like google and microsoft research and
like
so the company was very interesting i
mean like
it it kind of revolutionized this space
called like backups right
previously people used to do backups on
tapes and like tips are painful to
manage and so on and the founders had
this insight that there's a lot of
overlap
between consecutive backups they're
pretty much the same when you're like
backing up daily and then they kind of
build a new file system from scratch
to take advantage of that and they
revolutionize this whole backup industry
company did very well they examined ipo
within a couple of years it was
eventually acquired by emc and so on so
yeah that was was a great experience but
then after the company was acquired like
a lot of the team left frank life and so
on and i also have to like i mean i
always wanted to like do a startup and
so on so like left to do something on my
own
gotta um and what what was your role at
data domain what what kind of stuff were
you working on i'm curious
yeah and uh it's kind of interesting
like so data domain had like a core team
which
which worked on uh backups and like
short-term backups pretty much right i
mean you use you'd store the data for
like for like a month and three months
and like at most three months right and
then there was this market
for long-term archival of data right and
that's also related to my phd where we
looked at how do you store records for a
very very long time because there are
there are requirements in financial
industry that you need to keep stuff for
like seven years and then like 12 years
and like how do you design your system
to like to survive that like they're
like all the way from hardware
challenges like your discs will probably
not last like i mean think about like
hard drives you feel like 12 years ago
and so on how do you design your
hardware system to survive that long two
to like how do you do like file system
things how do you do duplication over
that long windows there are a lot of
challenges like uh like i it kind of led
that team which built out this long term
archival product at data
um so so then tell me what happened next
you said you you decided to start your
own company yeah so after data domain
like everyone was kind of like
we had a good exam like the company was
acquired by emc and then like most of
the team was gone and and said that okay
like i always wanted to be an
entrepreneur i mean i had tried once
before after my undergrad that didn't go
anywhere so i left in a domain with uh
to work on it
now thinking back it was a very stupid
idea i mean like i was trying to do
something um like identity and and
things like that so
it's like i mean again i i had no idea
how to be
like how to do market research and
things like that but i just left the
company data domain i'll work on this
and in three months i figured out that
this is not going anywhere
so i thought okay like i need to survive
so let's uh let's do some consulting the
excitement thankfully being a software
developer in the bay area it's pretty
easy for you to like find part-time
consulting stuff we work with i had
experience on like big data machine
learning did a lot of work around that
and like 2012 13 is when this was all
like catching up right so did a couple
of consulting gigs on the side
traveled a lot right i mean uh like my
daughter was born right then so like i i
wanted to spend some time with her as
well so that lined up well to travelled
a lot in europe in in
went back to asia for some time
so almost like a year and a half i i
kind of said i was having fun like doing
things on the side which you can like
switch off anytime you want
and and also like exploring startup
ideas so that's what pretty much was the
first two years after leaving their
domain first year and a half and then
they got bored with that at some point
and then like started a company called
mariana iq with two other co-founders so
yeah so that was my immediate journey of
the day
got it and was that your first
experience with customer data
yes so mariana iq was like literally my
first introduction to marketing as as a
tech right i mean like before my data
was like
yeah my phd data there's a lot of data
but i mean i have no idea like in fact
what what do marketing what does
marketing do like when i thought like
marketing was like this obscure team
sitting in a company writing like pdfs
and so on like they don't do much but
then
at mariana iq both my co-founders were
like ex-marketing people i like my ceo
co-founder he was he ran marketing for
juniper so like and the the vision of
the company was to like almost uh make
like build the next generation marketing
automation system so a lot of marketing
work was very manual but like marketing
has to come in and create campaigns and
like then create assets and figure out
like what audiences to
assign to what campaigns and run this a
b test and so on so there's like very
very manual
work and we thought like can we leverage
data and machine learning to like
automate a lot of that like can we
literally
like now this is a buzzword right i mean
like personalization at scale like
one-to-one marketing whatever like we
are trying to do that like using
everyone at that point so and so learned
a lot
the company didn't do so well because of
a lot of reasons part of what was the
biggest reason was like most marketing
teams do not have a lot of good data
that's that's kind of what we learned
the hardware including like some of the
largest companies we sold to like
microsoft and junipers and cisco
very very few marketing teams have good
data
so that's why i think like if you do not
have good data you cannot do machine
learning so like
kind of wonderful
but for for me it was like a fascinating
journey like learning about marketing
and like what are the use cases
yeah i've seen this in my um
entrepreneurial career over time is that
um it's funny how engineers can
sometimes get switched on to marketing
when they understand how much of it can
actually be quantitative
obviously there's qualitative marketing
as well and you know the positioning and
the narrative running the copy and all
the things on the campaigns but but the
the quantitative side of marketing is
actually quite fascinating and when an
engineer understands sort of how a
funnel works and how funnel
optimizations work
um and they understand how much of
marketing is really just based on on
math and
and um you know quantitative analysis um
it can be sort of a
a new light that engineers sometimes
especially entrepreneurs um come to see
and appreciate marketing in a new way
exactly i would say like anyone who
wants to do like data science at scale
and so on they should probably pick up
marketing problems and i would like like
i mean if you look at academia in
general like in data science like people
are working on like image recognition
they're like standard data sets but like
there's so much brain power being spent
on that like i wish there were like
marketing data sets people could look at
and so what i'm like it's happening in
the ad ecosystem in facebook's and
google's but like
but it's very much outside of academy
and so on but like there is so much
marketing beyond just ads
so yeah i mean like totally totally
agree
and so how did you work at mariana iq
prepare you to start rudder stack
usually i find some connection um you
know between ideas explored or
gaps um or sort of insights that
became apparent to a founder you know
along the journeys prior to them
starting the company i'm curious as to
um what that looked like for you uh
leading up to the rudder stack origin
yeah i think the biggest learning was
that uh like
marketing teams do not have data right
so like if you
if you have to enable like do any any ml
do anything like first like collect good
data right and
like set up those data pipelines and
then make sure that you have access to
that and then you can do like all the
other cool stuff so so we ended up
selling the company to a company called
eight by eight and and uh well like ebay
if you don't know is like a public voip
company
in the telecom space and
like me and the team was told like okay
now we have all these data go and figure
out what uh what he could do with this
data so and then like it's kind of
natural for us to pick up problems on
customer data space right so but then we
knew that
to solve the same set of problems like
can we do better lead scoring can we do
better marketing can we do like better
churn prediction and all these
interesting use cases of like customer
data but then we realize i mean like we
have to first solve the data problem
like from my mariana experience we get
the data first then we'll do ml and
which which itself was another learning
like getting data itself is not a
trivial exercise and the complexity of
like the data stack and the sources and
the volume and so on makes it really
complicated so
and then
pretty much like that what what we
learned the hard way at
mariana was like people don't have data
but eight by eight we kind of learned
the hard way that getting the data is a
hard problem let's solve that first and
then we'll eventually do all the cool ml
stuff
got it
so you saw a need for a new piece of
data infrastructure that didn't exist at
the time
um or or did it exist at the time i mean
i don't recall exactly when
segment was on the scene but they were
probably around from 20
20 14 14 or something probably right so
um did you see that segment was did you
acknowledge that they were in this
category were they in this category at
the time or did you feel like there was
a a big space um
empty space that nobody was really
attacking
yeah i mean like i like we i i knew of
segments like even at mariana right we
saw that journey but i mean we're kind
of like the same point started and then
like they they kind of found the right
fit like they focused on the data
infrastructure problem and then
the company just blew up right and like
i mean i like complete credit to them to
discover this like space that they can
like data integration in customer data
is a problem and like
the space they built the first solution
and then so on they have a great respect
for the company and the founders and so
on i think
what uh what i found interesting and the
reason i
uh like we are excited about a stack is
like i thought like segment was on a
great path
like they were solving the data
integration problem and that there's so
much they could do on top but then at
some point like 2018 19
they they switched to like focusing a
lot more on the marketing use cases so
like and and like they built the
personas product like maybe it was like
more bigger deals and so on so i think
like that pivot and that they change the
pricing structure and everything so
the company focused on like a slightly i
thought narrower use case where like the
use cases of customer data were well
beyond and then there's enough
opportunity just to like solve data
integration in in in a complete way so i
thought like they kind of like solved it
halfway and then
went a different direction for whatever
reason and so on
that was i guess like one of the things
one and the two
one other thing that i guess like we are
trying to uh
when i thought it was we need to do
differently is like
if you are selling to marketeers then
they want like a vertically integrated
start solution like give me one tool uh
where i can like create audiences and do
all the cool stuff i want but i don't
want to manage infrastructure i don't
want to worry about data warehouses
everything right so that's the path like
segment eventually went down and
the other hand like i was coming from
more of a data science data engineering
background right like marketing was one
use case but there are like so many
other use cases around like collecting
that data
analyzing building ml models and so on
so right
a slightly different architecture where
you had like complete access to the data
and then and like so that he could do
all this stuff right and that's where i
think was the key
reason i thought we started data science
gotta
yeah well let's let's let's talk about
some of those additional use cases um
because i think that when people hear
cdp or customer data they often think of
the marketing use cases um
what are some of these additional use
cases that you see as being interesting
yeah so i think like
like our customers like almost and we
have learned a lot from our customers in
in the last couple of uh uh like
years running a lot of stack right so
they like if you think from a customer
they almost like take a journey right
you when you had a very small startup
like five people 10 people then the use
case of customer data is like i built
the app i want to collect all the data
and send it to either google analytics
so that i can do some analysis and then
send it to amplitude on expandable and
then so on to do some product analytics
and then maybe i'll send it to some
marketing tools like to braise and then
so on to do like some marketing
automated
everybody starts right i want to use
some sas tools and i don't want to do
three integrations like so that's where
you can use the other stack and second
let's start we call it like the stack
zero
then once you are slightly more mature
like they're like 20 people and you
hired like a data engineer or a data
scientist now look at this data you want
to collect this data and dump into some
kind of a data warehouse and 10 years
back there were no data warehouses now
like it's so easy to like collect this
data and like
dump it into snowflake and and why do
you do that like there are use cases
that cannot be met by like these sas
tools like once i switch all the stats
right i mean there are some advanced
reports you want to build like there are
some custom things for your business
that you want to do like custom
dashboards right so that's the first
second uses of like starting collecting
this data into a data warehouse and and
building those things right
now as your organization matures a bit
more and like so the data stack is a
good example and we have a bunch of
customers in the third stage where you
are not just collecting the data into a
warehouse but you are now like
making that data actionable right so
good example is like we for example
collect the data uh there's all this
activity data and use it to score leads
like i mean our sales team wants to know
which of the leads signing up are more
active and not so that they want to ride
so you want to build this architecture
you want to collect the data into the
warehouse and then you want to like
activate it back now you see this
category called reverse etl which is
like basically doing this right like
taking the data out of the warehouse and
pushing it out but like what what
happens in between is still like very
rule-based like simple rules around how
many times somebody has logged in in the
last seven days like that is used for a
proxy for scoring and so on right so
that's that's the third layer where
you're like activating the data but then
it's still very rule based
when you become more mature
that's when you build like more ml
models right i mean now you have a data
scientist who can like not just do
rule-based things
in something like dvd but like they can
train like a ml model to do second sims
use cases around scoring recommended
segmentation and you see a lot of
similar use cases around like mostly
customer churns segmentation and so on
and so that that's the
fifth stage in in in in that journey
and but still the use cases are batch
like in the sense like you want to if it
is a score uh turn score you push it
back into some tool then you send them
some promotion and so but it's like very
bad use cases
finally you see like real-time use cases
of customer data like when you are like
really advanced yeah you're now now
you're at scale like a couple of hundred
people like you have a couple of million
users that's what you want to do like
real-time personalization and of the app
itself and so that's kind of like the
journey that every company takes
and
and like
i think like
if you look at the existing cdp's like
marketing is a very small fraction of
this right i mean like this is the
journey i mean if you think of like
companies like amazon and the capital it
is not the marketing team which put
together this customer data stack right
it is the engineering the data teams and
so on so
yeah
so so you felt there was an opportunity
with better stack to
build this infrastructure
that was targeted at data engineers and
data teams and not
not simply just the marketing team or
um or any business sort of vertical
um user group or use case for that
matter
um so what what's the origin story of
rudder stack like how did you get the
company together how did you find your
co-founders and what were some of the
early early challenges in the early days
yeah and like
so that itself was an interesting
journey right i mean
uh like i like we kind of uh like i knew
about i've been working in this space
and knew that there is a problem to be
solved here
partnered with this uh guy called sweat
giant
i don't know if you know him but he's a
partner at s28 capital i've known him
for years and
stayed in touch with him and so the
company itself was incubated at s28 so
like although i i'm like i don't have a
co-founder in a traditional sense of
co-founder but like this was incubated
at s28 like schwett was very closely
involved and definitely the first year
but even now he's like super involved in
the company so this is technically like
a part-time co-founder there is a word
like that so yeah that's kind of the
journey is 28 invested in the um the the
the seed round of the company and then
yeah i mean like i think we got very
lucky with finding product market fit uh
like early enough right i mean
like i have been on the other side with
my previous two startups where like we
struggled with product market fade and
we went to like and so on and i've seen
what the not-so-great looks like and now
i'm seeing what it looks like so i think
i mean i'm truly like i think like
we got lucky it's probably the
right way to say that but
now it's for us to go and execute so
anyway so that was like
uh and then we have been like growing
since then
and what was the product um or what was
the incarnation of the product that you
found product market fit for was it were
you open source from the earliest days
or
um what like what what did the early
traction look like yeah i think like
so this was always the vision right
build the stack to enable all these use
cases i talked about like some simple
stack to the complex stack right and so
on but like when we went go to market it
felt like
like building an open source alternative
to something like segment in this case
like that it was a good way to like put
on hack and use so like two open source
was like a very interesting strategy for
us i mean i thought like unlike other
open source companies where you have an
open source project which became very
popular and then there was a company
like here we raised money before every
single line of code were raised right so
we are pretty clear that we are building
a business here and open source felt
like i mean like a lot of traditional uh
sectors were like were kind of being
like uh like
impacted by open source i thought okay
like cdp makes sense to try an open
source strategy particularly because we
are going after the developer person
right so so we we we open source the uh
they call ourselves our cdp or an open
source alternative to the cdp's and went
on how can you use like the the this
blew up in hacker news so i think that
that helped us a lot of in our initial
goals
so many companies have again come out of
hack news i mean i i cannot find them
enough
so you were committed to
being the the open source alternative
for cdp
from the very earliest days yeah i mean
like
a hundred percent but
last year's has been a very interesting
learning for us right i mean and in
terms of like seeing the growth on open
source but also seeing the growth on
cloud right so and what that means for
us so yeah i mean like
yeah i mean we're still figuring out
like what uh
what is the longer term uh plan around
open source and then so on but i think
on the core product we are we are open
source very much committed to that
and do you have any advice for other
founders out there who may be wrestling
with the open source versus
commercial offering
at the onset of their company because
i talked to lots of founders who
um
you know some have some sort of take
this middle of the road approach where
they they they think they're building a
commercial product or a cloud product
but they're kind of dabbling in open
source and they're engineers and so they
think open source is cool and they think
they should be open sourcing like pieces
of their thing and and they don't really
like you know come
come with both feet on one side or the
other um
what do you think about that like what's
your take on
coaching founders as to when is the
right time to adopt an open source
strategy or not yeah i mean i i i don't
know if i'm qualified enough to comment
on that because like these are some of
the challenges we are also like trying
to figure out and as we scale the
company and i think like
i hear that the challenges remain even
at like companies like [ __ ] and
confluent like they are like much much
bigger of where we are right so
this is a challenge that is there's a
conflict that is always there in the
company but one thing i guess like
couple of things people have known is
like open firstly like the the there are
three business models around open source
one is like service based right where
your the core product is open source and
you're just selling services on top like
that's what red hat did and i think like
that business model is dead right
everyone agrees you'll be able to raise
money on that
and build a company then the second
business model was around open code
right where you have a cold offering and
then you have like value-added uh
products on top of the core offering and
and even that i think like is like and
generally the the the assumption there
is like then it's like an on-prem
offering like you download the software
you run it yourself and so on and then
like you buy some additional services on
top to like
on which you make money but this whole
business of like your customers
downloading the software and setting it
up is painful for the customer and also
painful for you to support and
manage and so on so even open code is
i think generally people believe it's
kind of dead and you have
if you look at the
companies like confluence and then who
have both the models right they have
like an on-prem offering which on which
you can
pay and
get more value-added services and there
is a cloud offering so cloud is where
all that growth is right i mean the open
code is almost like distraction so
so that's that is also
like it's probably dead right so then it
comes the cloud right and you have an
open source product for people to play
with feel happy about and set it up if
some custom customers will do it but
then like you also have a cloud offering
right and people have the choice of
going open source and or going cloud so
that's the path we interpret almost like
at the same time we open source the
product we also within a month we had a
cloud offering
and we had a generous fleet here where
you can try the cloud product as well if
you want to or you can use open source
right so and we saw the growth on the
feet here on the cloud and the open
source and cloud was clearly awareness
so it was like an interesting learning
for us and
as again like as a buyer i think it
makes sense right if i'm a data engineer
i i like something being open source i
can play with it look at the code this
is a lot of good feeling about it but
when i'm running this like
at night i don't want to get a page call
like this something is down i mean i'd
rather give it to like a cloud unless
there are strong compliance reasons and
all the stuff but like that becomes like
uh less and less of a concern people are
buying onto the cloud
so anyway long way to answer your
question i don't exactly answer it as
well because we ourselves are figuring
out
yeah i think you're right um obviously
to observe that the cloud hosted version
of a lot of these open source projects
is becoming the
de facto way to go um the interesting
thing that that creates is
then there's a sort of an obvious break
between
the the upgrade path between the people
who have your open source bits and we're
playing around with it and then who
actually become users of your cloud
product which is a completely different
signup process and could you know
integration and whatever
um so i think what we're seeing in the
open source world is that you know
because of this transition to cloud is
real
um but now maybe there's not as obvious
sometimes of a benefit from having the
open source bits out in the wild because
they don't necessarily turn into an
automatic upgrade pass to your cloud
service like your cloud service could
just have a free tier and you know that
that could be kind of essentially the
same from a go to market standpoint like
reducing friction and sort of getting
customers and man do engineers like
really need to like security audit like
your your code like for most of their
use cases like not
not really so i guess like this is kind
of where i'm seeing a bit of a of a
break in in some of the open source
um religion is because there's not
always an automatic upgrade easy upgrade
path you don't you cannot automatic
automatically capture all the value you
have in those open source bits and
directly translate it to your cloud
service but i don't know i i don't know
how you see that or if you're if these
are some of the things that you're that
you're working through as well okay yeah
hundred percent i i'm with you on that i
think when i look at like the longer
term revenue potential of the company i
don't think open source like directly
has very little contribution i mean like
all our revenue comes from like the
cloud update right
we are not like selling anything on the
open source right i think
one thing though is like and which is
very hard to quantify is like
long-term impact of open source i mean
like there are there's still a developer
community who's passionate about open
source and they'll like spread good
words about you and like and so on
i don't know how to quantify that so
that's the reason i guess like
yeah i think
yeah yeah and let's let's be honest like
rudder stock was such a story because he
positioned as the open source cdp like
right out of the gate like it seems to
to me in your case
at the earliest days there was no
question that open source was
at least optically like the the thing
that that pushed the company into the
forefront and
um even if that
you know sort of morphs over time you
got a ton of like launch value from that
um so that that's also fascinating right
and and that can't be that can't be
dismissed
exactly hundred percent we would not not
been here if not for that open source
thing going
up on hacker news and so on
yeah great
um well these are fun issues to to
debate and to discuss and and watch you
know as as other companies
are also tackling the same thing and and
obviously we you know we promote and
believe deeply in open source here at
data council
um
but you know i'm also an investor and
there's um
you know money to be made by companies
who are doing the right things and
bringing the right tools to market and
so um this is often a question i i get
into with early founders engineer
founders it's this discussion about how
do you sort of weigh the trade-offs
between initial open source offering
versus a commercial offering so
obviously the jury's still out but we'll
we'll continue to explore this with the
community
um so i want to like dig in a little bit
more to the um some of the uniquenesses
of rudder stock um you know besides just
its open source nature um
what are some of the i mean i i i think
most the community understands basically
or whatever stock does but why don't you
give us just a quick run through of the
core features of rudder stock and how
folks use it and then we can go a little
bit deeper from there
yeah i think
like what we have
like so i'll go back to that
journey that i talked about it that
every customer takes and you from the
simplest stack where you want to collect
like your first party data from your app
and and send to all these different
destinations right and and and that's
where the pain point is typically i
don't want to integrate like five
different sdks and each one is has its
own way of like sending events and how
do you do consistency and all the stuff
right so that stack and data stack will
guarantee uh even delivery to all of
them and so on i think that that reduces
your coding effort it
creates like more it creates a
consistent view across all these
different
data destinations and it reduces your
code
like
like i mean generally you don't want to
load too many javascript for performance
reasons and so on that's where
that's the core value problem like
simplifying uh like data integration at
that layer right and and so that we
that's our core product like the event
streaming product but then
the as as you go to the second and third
stage of the stack there you want to
like collect all these data into a data
warehouse and and then you want to do
some like transformations like dvd
transformations and then so on and then
you take you want to take the output and
send it to some destinations right like
back what do you call the reverse etl
and category today right so we enable
that part too right we we have the
reverse edl product so we can get the
data into the warehouse we can take that
out of the warehouse and send to
different destinations at that point you
also want to bring some third-party data
you want to bring some data from
salesforce maybe you want to bring your
ticketing data to create that complete
customer profile so we have those data
points as well right collect and like
bring third-party data first-party data
send the data back from the warehouse
from our perspective these are all like
different interesting ways when you want
to move customer data and that's what we
have built
a complete solution to like solve all
customer data integration problems right
so that that's where the companies today
that's what we are monetizing and i
think that's a
big revenue opportunity as like segments
and the other companies have shown
but and
and so building you mentioned so um
building on top of the on top of the
data warehouse is is a big
um thing for you guys and and does it do
you feel this differentiates you from
other
players
yeah hundred percent i think like that
is the poor like if you just tell like
what is how do you differentiate with
this other cdps the number one
differentiator is like build everything
around your data values we believe that
like everything your customer data
should be in your warehouse and we have
built the plumbing layers today and
we'll do lot more it's not just the
plumbing right but but yeah could you
have built the plumbing layers of data
in and out of your warehouse and so on
and the other big focus is like the
persona itself right i mean like most
cdp's are trying to sell to the
marketing persona and we are like
laserville the the data teams and so on
got it
um so so what are some of the
interesting architectural decisions you
made when building rudder stack like
where do you feel you
[ __ ] a trend or um or learned from
others um
can you give us some examples of some
some more interesting architectural
aspects of the platform
yeah i think uh
i mean one thing i would say a little
bit i i don't think we did differently
but like probably it was the natural
thing to do is like to build like for
the cloud native world it's a bed on
kubernetes and like
this this whole thing from days you know
even whether it's
open source whether it's a commercial
offering like something like we kind of
bet on kubernetes like we deployed we
distribute it as helm charts and docker
images and so on so that's kind of one
big thing we
did other thing it was like again
because we wanted this to be distributed
like not just by run by us
but but but our customers
well actually one other thing we did was
look around this notion of a control
plane data plane separation right so
again this has become like a standard
these days but uh like a lot of other
tradition like if you see companies
which are built in the 2012 13 14
timeframe like they're not have this
architecture right but you have this
control plane which is hosted by us the
data plane is where all the data flows
through and the data plane can be run in
in by us in a cloud offering it could be
running customers vpc it could be run by
an open source user on a laptop and so
on so this control plane data plane
separation gives you a lot of
flexibility and control over data
movement right so that's kind of one
other architectural choice today
other thing we did was like build almost
like a streaming engine on top right
typically you would build like
if you had to design this you like maybe
use kafka or one of these like streaming
solutions but like we build our own
thing because we we felt that this is a
piece of software we want to have
complete control over and like and i
have managed copter clusters in in the
past and it's a pain right so
so you so you support streaming data
well i guess um sort of sort of by
nature um the data streams through
rudder stack um did you fully embrace
the streaming paradigm in your own
architecture or is this like micro
batches and other other other types of
of things
no it's fully streaming right i think
that's where
just like we differentiate with the like
i mean we started with the event
streaming right so that's built on
streaming and and
even our etl and reverse etl solutions
they're also kind of built using the
core engine which is streaming
so so we we can do very interesting
things with the
like the the etl side of the reverse
retail side because the core engine is
streaming you know how do you transform
and so on but yeah like like like
streaming was extremely important
because uh like some of these
the first useless i was talking about
where you want to collect first party
data and send it to like different
destinations right and like we have
customers who are
triggering sensitive well not sensitive
like time
dependent like strict requirements
around like timing like i mean password
reset emails are being sent through data
stack events right so you cannot be
delayed by more than like 20 seconds
like whatever
and so because of the strict sls if you
look at a traditional etl world or
reverse epl what is fine i mean if it
did is very much anyway it's like
landing data like once in a couple of
hours
got it
um so so very interesting that you guys
run directly on top of the customers
data warehouse um you also use the term
modern data stack in describing you know
how things are are evolving in the space
i'm curious um
what other tools do you play nicely with
in the modern data ecosystem
yeah i think like
when when you think about the modern
data stack like the the key components
are the data integration layer
which is like moving data in and out and
i think like yeah we are one of the
vendors but then they're like etl
vendors like five trans of the world and
so on
like of course they have a lot better
coverage for use cases beyond customer
data we are just focused on customer
data so integration is one one big piece
then
the other core pieces like the data
warehouse itself like that is everything
is centered around that so like
snowflake or red shape or big query
and then you have like like newer age
like firebolt and materialize they're
all like
coming up with interesting uh angles to
this data warehouse
problem right uh the the so
integration was getting data in and out
warehouses where you store then you do
transformations on top of that data
right so there are like two parts one is
like traditional sql transformations
right so if you do it in sql and you do
your modeling in look ml if you're doing
metrics kind of stuff or or dvds like
everybody
does dvd transformations that are the
other big players in this
then there is the visualization layer
you connect some some kind of a bi tool
on to that right so they're like
tableaus and lookers of the world
and
the other part is like the ml path right
where you don't like you're not doing
simple transformations you're like
training ml models and things around
that so
uh
so the the the the problems that are
around creating that feature store and
how to store these features in the
warehouse how do you make them like
keep them updated how do you make it uh
like online
we are going to do some interesting
things around feature store and so on
but then there are other features for
companies where just focus on the people
and then like
the whole ml ecosystem right i don't
know like around like sagemakers and
like google vertex
yeah i'm curious i'm curious about that
later because you talked earlier about
how sort of in your model of
um you know customer customers journey
through their own cdp types of
applications
that that ml
um you know training models machine
learn machine machine learning model is
based on the data is kind of the
the last step in the process for the
most sophisticated customers
um i'm just curious like which tools you
see as emerging
um at that layer of the stock that are
being used by your customers now um you
know if any uh to integrate with better
stack and perform that um ml or auto ml
type activity um on their own data
yeah i think the
the
like the biggest uh like i mean i
actually one thing that has been i've
been most impressed with with is like
bigquery ammo so
like the way they have made it really
easy to like train ml models on top of
your data warehouse and and make them
like
production ready and so on like that
that i think we have a bunch of
customers who are doing things on
bigquery ml so that's
that i think is interesting then like we
see a bunch of these like uh
automl companies right where you have
the data in the warehouse and then you
like create this user table which we
call the user table where you have the
users and all the features about the
user and so on and then now you want to
train a churn model or you want to train
something and you know
like they're two approaches either you
like
go wrong you you connect the jupiter
notebook to that you load it build a
model and
either you're in the database ecosystem
data breaks or sagemaker or whatever or
if you don't have the team then we see
some people like would just connect
something like h2o or or data robot to
the same data in in a warehouse and like
get a model
up and running in like in minutes so
like
customers depending on the
solidification of the
of the teams
like i mean that h2o
that that ecosystem has probably because
we primarily sell to the data and data
science schemes so that's not super
prevalent but we do see like bigquery ml
is i think pretty interesting and the
traditional like the database world and
the sagemaker world
yep got it
um so so back to rudder stack itself
what are what's the roadmap for
um the the near future and what are you
able to share with us that you're
excited about most excited about in
terms of the rudderstack product roadmap
yeah i think like the way we even think
about this is like enable our customers
to take this whole journey right like
from simple to the most complex and the
the the next thing that i can
talk about is like creating that user
feature store if you will right i mean
data stack will collect all this raw
data for you like even data and the etl
data
they're just dumped into this all these
raw tables but then some data engineer
has to go in and write like the dvd jobs
or spark jobs to like do identity
switching and then compute features
right so some a feature could be like
somebody
how many times somebody has logged in in
the last seven days like that's a very
simple feature but there were complex
features like like has this person come
to the checkout page and dropped off in
the last three days or something like so
there's all these features people are
interested in like for your doctrine
processing and then today they have to
go and write like dvd projects or like
or write them spark things on the raw
tables that data stack is dumping to
compute these features right so what we
are
we are going to uh what we are working
on is like how do you like make that
really easy like so that somebody
doesn't have to like
write and write that code and run that
pipeline
right so that's kind of
and then once you have this clean
feature store or whatever you want to
call it and then like how do you
activate
then there are multiple users of this
there is like ml users there are like
simple activation you say users and then
you connect to some kind of a bi tool
and do dashboarding so all our use cases
of that user table so but that's what
we'll do the first step of creating that
table and then hopefully we'll take the
next step after that now that user table
is there can you like get a
off-the-shelf model that you can just
like point to that table and get
something up and running so yeah but
like was further out i think it's
interesting that you're calling this um
this feature the the feature store
versus the metric store um
because it seems to me that um if a
company is sort of more tilted towards
analytics they call this metric store
and if they're tilted more towards
machine learning they call this the
feature store is this to say that
i mean obviously you're taking cues from
your customers and in market research
but like how do you see this feature
store
metric store
um overlap uh in in in your world yeah i
think that that's very interesting i
think like uh like i like
i mean
the world is forming an opinion on this
also right so when i don't know how much
can i english i mean by no means i am an
expert in this but i i guess like one
thing we're learning is like the
requirements are slightly different for
like for a metric and and and like an
and a feature right and for example
like
uh like let's say you have a revenue
metric
then you don't need like
too much historic data like what was the
revenue on like like last year this time
and so on when you're talking about
features you actually need to keep track
of that right historic versions of those
features because unless you are training
a churn model like somebody turned last
september so then you want to know the
fee if you're training a model then you
need to know what are the feature values
like how many times he has logged in
before he turned right side last
september and so on right so
for these models like you
you need to go to historic versions of
the features
i guess that's one key difference
between
metric store and so on
yeah what makes sense yeah
yeah and is this functionality that you
would build natively um into rudder
stack or is this an integration or are
you still deciding that
yeah i think
like
metric stored uh we don't have a strong
opinion that what exactly what what is
part of rather stuff what is not but
like but like at least the user features
like feature store is also a broad thing
i mean like you can do ml for a lot of
things uh but like when it the way we
think about this is like
like we are collecting the data we know
the data schema we know what are the
events you are collecting and and so on
right so we we know like how
we can ask you how do you do identity
speaking and then creating this user
table like we actually want we will call
it user table we don't even want to call
user feature table like it's a user
table uh
in the marketing world you call it
customer 360 or whatever but like i mean
that's also a marketing diagram so like
that's the table we will instantiate
right and and like and that will have
features around that user at different
points in time but uh but yeah i mean
that's
that makes sense and then now you can
point multiple things to that and
awesome well it's great to hear about
your vision for the product and the
space and
um
i i have just another question to ask
you before i let you go
um besides how can people contact you if
they have more questions which i'll ask
you in a minute but um my my
my last question um is
what surprised you most about your work
in the data ecosystem so far
yeah
mean yeah i was thinking about uh
this
i
yeah i mean
like when when i was doing my grad
school right and
in my ph like 2007-8
i i'm like like we are working on this
high performance computing as i was
saying right and i thought like all
problems in data have been solved right
i mean this is a dead field i mean like
because people have been doing high
performance computing for like 30 years
before that right so i thought like like
there are no interesting data problems
to be solved in 2007 so like i i picked
my phd was actually not on like high
performance data like we did more of
like security and and and so on but like
i mean like i mean how long was i i mean
like if you look at like 15 years later
they're still interesting companies
being formed there's still like a lot of
interesting problems in data so yeah
it's it's kind of amazing like how this
like it's just exploding yeah exactly
yeah
yeah well it's great it's great to have
you in rutterstack part of it um we're
looking forward to seeing you at data
council austin coming up
and excited about your participation
there
so we hope to see you in the team there
and until then i'm curious how could
people get a hold of you if they have
other questions or want to learn more
about rudderstock yeah i mean i'm on
linkedin or like email my first name
somewhere there which is not the easiest
to pronounce
we'll make sure we spell it right in the
in the youtube listing so people know
know how to find you
email and order linkedin is the best way
to connect okay sounds good
well um samia deb thanks for chatting
with me it's really been a pleasure and
um excited you know to see rudder stack
continue to
do great things in the data ecosystem
and and so we're wishing you the best of
the company thanks a lot and thanks
again for having me really nice chatting
with you i had a lot of fun
and thanks to our listeners for joining
once again
uh we'll have more dc thursday is coming
up uh next month and uh also don't
forget that data council austin is
coming uh we've moved the dates because
of kovid it's now march 23rd and 24th
2022 so we hope that you can join us and
the rest of the data community
in austin you can find more information
on data council dot ai slash austin
so until then don't forget to subscribe
on youtube so you can get notified of
more awesome dc thursdays that are
upcoming and we'll see you around the
data community soon